bella a tutti i ragazzi e belle nuti
addio
io sono con dj cosa si fosse capito
siamo nella mia vecchia camera non è
vero di screen e allora ti giochi netto
oggi ragazzi ho preparato dei nomi un po
strani per questo video ha voluto
pensare a diverse cose diane reeves gate
e matarazzo che il bambino di essere
gestiti solo più iconico e di ripartire
proprio da lui
giochiamo e dà veramente un sacco di
tempo che non faccia chi network quindi
vedo che è migliorato anche graficamente
l'hanno rifatto perfetto perché faceva
schifo prima anche adesso come desidera
un azione non è vero adesso è migliorata
selezione al tema della prossima partita
personaggio animali perché può
indovinare anche gli animali il tuo
personaggio è nato in italia allora
parliamo di vivace delle diete a
parlando di lui litigate che peraltro
non ho mai capito come si pronuncia
gating hatten introverso ragionata
italia noto personaggio esisterà vero sì
ma non esiste il sottosopra però sono
già morto non anche nomi spoilerare per
il tuo personaggio a che fare quel mondo
dello sport in rosa già un attore ies ha
più di 40 anni no recitarono di uno
studente è uno studente ma non fa quello
giorno per la digital ruolo di kaneda o
no la sangio fa parte della serie
televisiva gli americano ies a che fare
con stranger things attenzione entriamo
nel mamma mia che sei fortissimo sì
comunque ai capelli ricci sembrano più
dei noodles quando li bagni però si sa
mai baciato la protagonista no alla
pelle scura no fa parodie
immaginate tipo demo gorgone pagherai tu
no gate e matarazzo va bene hai ragione
sei bravo complimenti solo tremila volte
l'anno indovinato mi fa chiedere quanto
ci mette indovinare meno perché da un po
che non lo faccio e non avrebbero essere
innocenti come è per essere go centrico
indosso ai siti femminili non solo a
volte è un attore no e nell'azienda
italiana si e no a youtuber si sa che
fare con dei videogiochi si sa che fare
coi mezzi note famoso grazie a minecraft
no alla barba no a che fare con fa vj se
tu per con vestibilità l'aiea fa parte
di meise l'hai già chiesto prima no ha
pubblicato un video solchi nator
ma non lo so se l'ho mai fatto mamma mia
famiglia delle un attimo hai ragione ma
fammi vedere la foto che raggiungerà per
primo a dieci voti vincerà rosa adesso
funziona a chi network e cambia
l'immagine ogni tot no e la voti tour e
c'è questa che è stata una delle mie
foto profilo e poi c'è questa beh mi
sembra ovvio che votiamo questa dove
sembra non drogatevi mi raccomando beh
ovvio guarda madonna ragazzi indovinato
60 695 mila volte c'è incredibile
siccome sono una persona molto riservata
non parlo mai della mia vita privata ma
sono curioso di vedere se indovina le
mie ex vediamo è un casino questo disco
però vediamo dai vediamo cosa dice il
tuo personaggio famoso grazie a youtube
ambientate famoso ai miei però vabbè un
canale di no è una donna si vince 9 anni
yes ai capelli colorati no di vita è il
soprano di ex numero 1 cioè stan due ha
mai avuto i bambini o mio dio non lo so
perché l'abbiamo vissuto in toscana si
che non ci credo e biondo si viva
firenze si no ha beccato dagli stabili
ha beccato a fidanzata di step ha
sbagliato ma è stato ferito come
garibaldi nel senso ad alcuni il cuore
sono ferito emotivamente si no posso
certo tipo io avevo fatto scene di nudo
anche questo non gliel'ho mai chiesto
no avrà fatto scene di noodles ma non lo
so io sei single adesso musicali non ho
gioca in italia gioca che no vive con la
propria madre si ha girato di non lo so
non gliele killian e fidanzato non lo so
non penso
l'ex ragazza di step l'ici
non si ricarica nessuno tutte le ex di
stefani hai sbagliato però a testa
all'anno in escandescenza e personaggi
ha recitato in scarface
sì ma mettiamo di no a una sorella si
aveva i capelli ricci no sto pensando a
niente
ho finalmente hai ragione complimenti no
ovviamente non so cosa dire che comunque
niente comunque indovinato meno di me
quindi fantastico dove ai ragazzi
proviamo con ex numero due
chissà cosa mischieranno dopo sto video
speriamo che non arrivi mai allora il
tuo personaggio è nato in italia femmina
si sa più 19 anni si è uno di tuber
noemi e un suo familiare no è famoso non
ho avuto dei figli
lo voglio chiedere non lo so è mai stato
innamorato di lei no lo faceva per soldi
quando passano già più di 25 anni ma non
penso i tuoi personaggi nato a maggio
non fate domande sul dove quando sono
nate per forza a entrambi gli occhi si
ha un cellulare base ha subito una
trasformazione non è stato scoperto la
conosce di persona
ma mi dà la risposta sta pensando a
roberta carlucci rowbury no non siamo
mai stati insieme
però però bella fu bella foto bella foto
bella foto per la foto non è il 2003 mm
f sarebbe stato molto strano però
vediamo se mi becca mio padre a quel
punto il tuo personaggio youtuber no
dosate video rimasti si viene
dall'italia beh certo a che fare con la
musica mio padre si sa che fare con la
musica però non so se qualcuno non l'ha
saputo però ha più di 50 anni si è nati
l'emilia romagna no è nato a napoli no è
considerato il re dei mari
ha una forma fallica mio padre basic
come è pelato però non penso ai capelli
castani no ai capelli mio padrone
capelli ma come niente va come niente da
eco impegnati maledizione il suo
personaggio va figli maschi
oh sì almeno un figlio famoso si sa che
fare con fari j.cole l'unico figlio
famosa del mondo e sono io
non è possibile una prima possibile time
ci sono un sacco di madri e padri di
youtube come com'è possibile che metta
un figlio famoso esco solo io comunque
si mio padre
esattamente c'è una foto mi ha
aggiustato mio padre è presentato da
bottiglia a2 e che comunque è stato
indovinato 76 mila volte porcaccia vacca
sono contento vabbè papa posso cerco
mamma però volevo provare la versione
animali che era l'ultima questa cosa qua
che non avevo ancora provato quindi una
tu pensi a un animale va bene allora
proviamo a pensare a per il mito rinco
l'ornitorinco il tuo animale si può
trovare in casa
se gliela faccio è un animale per il
ornitorinco l'anima e famoso però un
animale toni ma ne fa le fusa no ai peli
si a quattro zampe a quattro zampe è un
roditore no alle orecchie non è le
orecchie cavolo novità ricorrono alle
orecchie che saranno cioè c'è la brama
ci avrà inteso però che bello
l'ornitorinco lo voglio e bellissimo non
all'orecchio gola no a otto zampe non ne
ha 4 alle zampe basta questa domanda
questo allevati nella fattoria non fa
paura hanno poi dormire con le persone
no e appuntito una cicala mamma mia che
schifo che favore degli animali
ragazzino ha indovinato niente pensiamo
a una cosa molto più semplice tipo
pietro ragazzi io come ultima proverei
l'armadillo perché l'armadillo merita
dai sì bus 9 in tuffo dicono che il mio
canale non è istruttivo armadillo
trovare in casa no alle ali no a quattro
zampe si mamma mia la mia ignoranza in
materia incredibile comunque sì mamma
mia che carino no credo che mangi carne
sai è più alto di nuovo no si può
spazzolare ma non ne ho idea
non penso lo trovi potrà sì quasi
dappertutto no viveva nel cretaceo non
lo so alle dita già le dita cioè le
unghiette che belle
beh più belle più o meno fanno schifo
però no lancia acqua non lo so se un
pokémon si no perché poi vai pensare al
canguro si può stazionare no el 1
tensione un pangolino usate mino adesso
fammi cerca veramente uguale un
armadillo
molto si perché che animale è un panino
no hai sbagliato fai schifo però ma non
a quanto sembra un po e l'evoluzione
dell'armadillo cioè l'armadillo che si è
voluto ora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
questo era chi nei torre aggiornato
bello e proms tra robello solo mio padre
oggi illuminato animali tutto però mio
padre si è anche detto che ha una forma
fallica prova proprio vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se vi è piaciuto ci vediamo
qua con la mia cameretta anche nel
prossimo video lasciato un bel commento
di piace iscrivetevi al canale cliccate
la campanella che quindi rimanete
aggiornati sono i video come sempre ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]